as the war in ukraine continues vladimir
putin is trying to squeeze the west
using one of his most powerful weapons
the oil and gas that flows to europe and
keeps the lights on
in retaliation over fuel payments and
worsening sanctions he stopped supplying
gas to bulgaria and poland
if someone intends to interfere from the
outside and there are threats of a
strategic nature they must know that our
response to counter-strikes will be
lightning fast rapid we have all the
tools we need
poland says it has reserves and
alternative supplies it knew this moment
may come
russia has pushed the border of
imperialism gas imperialism another step
further this is a direct attack on
poland
an attack that europe is trying to stop
by reducing reliance on russian energy
it comes as no surprise
that the kremlin uses fossil fuels to
try to blackmail us
the kremlin failed once again
in his attempt to sow division among
member states
the era of russian fossil fuel in europe
is coming to an end
but that's easier said than done
especially here in germany which before
the ukraine conflict started received
more than half its gas from russia
it has a plan to shrink this to zero but
says it could take years
this country is now contemplating what
was once unthinkable that vladimir putin
might turn off gas supplies now if that
happens or even if there's an immediate
europe-wide embargo germany's central
bank has warned of recession
and that will cause problems elsewhere
germany is of course the key economy in
the euro area and in europe and in the
very moment after germany goes into us
into a recession
all other countries suffer with it
because we have all these trade
relationships with the countries
for now bulgaria and poland adjust to
their new reality and europe
contemplates a new front in an economic
war
and all the uncertainty that comes with
it
hannah thomas peter sky news in berlin